hey welcome to famine on Batman this
week Kim is in Canada we got a special
guest I'm gonna tell you what is this is
fattening on Batman or this week we've
decided to call it black man on Batman
cuz I gotta guess what I say holy [ __ ]
actually my legal name
holy [ __ ] fill them up good morning
honey holy [ __ ] for Lamar how are you
phil lamarr last episode I think it was
Kevin and I were riffing as we do as one
does and we got to talking about the
fact that I was watching spider-man 2
one weekend and I noticed like the train
scene phil lamarr you know what else for
Lamar is everywhere he's like Leroy
gompa find it so he hits me on Twitter's
like Leroy Gump Leroy Leroy and it took
me a second remember where those drums
like oh you should come on the show so
now the kid is up prepping the flash a
second let's go the flash is directing
does Zoop I was like [ __ ] let's bring
another guest in let's do a show
let's do show with Phil let's do this
show how are you I'm good are you busy
I am busy because one looks at your IMDB
and there's 347 actor credits that's a
busy man well you know if you divide it
up by 30 years and I won't seem that if
I can impress it well still still you
look at people like oh that dude great
actor made 12 movies yeah this guy 347
credit that's right baby I work in
volume hey you know if you can't if you
can't pummel them equality pummel them
with quantity there it is not that he's
not [ __ ] awesome at his job so listen
let's let's let's let's go back ok let's
go way back alright we go about to go
all the way back hmm
tell me now you're a California kid
right yes sir born and raised in LA so
now and you went to
you know yes tell me how you get to yell
from Southern California Oh what did you
want to be when you grew up
that's a good question I'm still trying
to figure out what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna keep going with this acting thing
until something better comes along
excellent but so far so good
now my mother was a striver my mother
was one of eight kids out of Pine Bluff
Arkansas first a person in her family to
go to college and and I think perhaps
the first one to have only one child
which and she was all about achievement
and education and opportunities so yeah
grew up in LA we moved out of Inglewood
to the North Valley right about the time
they started bussing people from
Inglewood to the North Valley and I
think the only reason I got two yellows
to that extra hour of sleep all the
other brothers were getting up at 5:00
to get on the bus let's go I was
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and the
Chatsworth exactly and yeah I went to
Harvard Westlake which was a really good
private school and you know got into got
into Yale and I don't think it has
helped me at all in my career it almost
never does but I mean I mean at least
like if I want to work for the CIA that
[ __ ] would be very valuable I get
entertainment it kind of does not matter
where you went to school unless you want
to be a comedy writer then it helps to
have gone to Harvard wait yes if you
want to write for The Simpsons you have
to go to Harvard that's about it but I
mean I remember hiring kids who went to
Harvard right and I went to st. John's
University in Queens did not matter yeah
like I'm hiring that guy it just happens
to be the best guy but nobody gave a
[ __ ] where I went to school well and I
keep saying that you know you know as my
kids are getting older and my wife's
like what if I was like college is not a
thing believe me I went to Yale and I've
worked for a ton of [ __ ] who
went to state school so it really does
not you know it just go where you fit go
where you will get the most and Yale for
me was actually a place where I got a
fantastic perspective especially isn't
that California kid go in the East you
you get to see a little more of the
world you know and like although there's
something hilarious about meeting people
whose names have the same name as Pete
of buildings and you're like nobody you
got the same name is epic just that's my
great-grandfather oh oh that's okay I
see where you got it no you're really
smart right no I get so now when you
went to Yale what was the plan going
into you what did you want to be coming
out of you well you know what I had
started doing plays in junior high so
there was an interest and all the
schools I applied to had like drama type
programs although I wound up picking the
one with the actual least good
undergraduate program I I could have
gone to Northwestern I could've gone to
Carnegie Mellon I'm like let's go to
Yale but I'm thinking Yale Drama
that's a graduate program yeah
undergraduate we had like one full-time
faculty member like oh oh they don't
really want to teach me this run some
lines it's fine oh no this is where you
learn to be a drama Turk okay yeah no
that's alright I'm gonna go get my
degree in English because they get a
whole building you know did was there
ever any resistance from your family to
this line of work like knowing knowing
black people as I know black people
there is like my dad was an immigrant
from Haiti my mom Oh my mama second so
you've got hard-working black people I
got hard-working black people I got I
had nothing I came from the poorest
place on the world in the world to New
York City you have to be an accountant
like that was that was the Wow
when I told my dad like now I want a
major in film like well you watch enough
movies the passive-aggressiveness my dad
ever was was right I guess you watching
have movies and read enough comic books
so I guess I guess there are numbers in
that right so was there ever any like
hey so Philly you sure that's what you
want maybe a nice trade perhaps early on
my mother said something about maybe you
should major but I majored in English
Lit at Yale so it sounds good
I can teach you know exactly right so
yeah no I mean and also I am the least
flamboyant an interesting person in my
family so like the only question anybody
has like you okay so yeah no it was
everybody was always very supportive
well and also I started working
professionally in high school mmm-hmm
what was the first thing I did the mr. t
cartoon shut up when I was a junior in
high school were you one of the white
kids no come on no come on everybody was
ethnically you know correct in their
casting ah they had an Asian girl
playing the Asian girl and a white black
guy playing the black guy white guy
plaintiff like you know it was all
Pheebs you had to and a white
impressionist from Chicago playing mr. t
no mr. chases he showed up oh yeah
well that was the whole point doing
without mr. t I mean that's like I was
like making the cereal and not putting
him on the box actually I think the
cereal came before the cartoon I'm sure
that in terms of in terms of
merchandising he's like what did we do
we forget anything
he's got the action figure is like oh
[ __ ] we forgot a cartoon maybe you
should do that yeah let's get one of
those up well the a-team is still on the
air please nobody watched it it was
awful
well so was Chuck Norris's karate
commandos exactly oh you've got but
that's the thing it didn't matter it was
just something to sell and hey it was a
great summer job for three years that's
[ __ ] awesome still haven't met mr. do
she really you never he never recorded
with us damn it's like one of these days
you I'm coming for you tea
you'd think that would mean it like it
here here's what you do shitty car too
and pay a little bit of money but you
get to hang on mr. t nope no uh nope no
tea for you so now in all this were you
a nerd
were you a geek from way back when did
it start for you well I'm a reader mmm
like anybody in my family like the nose
like you when actors like it was always
read and blue
we are playing he just sitting in a
corner with his book so yeah I read
comics I read fantasy I have an entire
robert e Howard Conan collection of the
the paperbacks and the all around the
camps once he wants Robert E Howard
today yes yeah I got a few Conan the the
earth sir / yes oh but all those
beautiful presented covers but yeah I
was I was a huge comic book I inherited
my next-door neighbours collection I was
ten and he was coming back from college
he's like I'm not gonna read these
anymore so I had a bunch of books I had
a bunch of Silver Age stuff that I
wouldn't otherwise have had access to
you know I've said a couple of mad
magazines that are older than I am holy
[ __ ] so I still have those although I'm
a reader not a collector so you know I
the only reason I have a collection is
because I'm also a little bit of a
hoarder yeah and I can't throw stuff I
can't especially a book you can't throw
out a book I know like I've shifted to
that - look is a kid I had these seven
or eight long boxes under the bed
because my mom wouldn't let me just have
them out but as time went on like I just
became I want to read I don't
necessarily need to have like exactly
I've turned into a trade person I know
that kills all the people who like me
have written comics and need to actually
sell floppies I'm like I know I know I'm
a trade guy don't have the space for it
anymore
by the digital issues I do that too I do
that too I do them both but when what
I'm keeping I'm keeping the trade
it's trades okay but yeah okay so so the
comics the novels D&D or my other nerds
I was a pretty big movie guy not like
deep deep movie TV was my jamm from 1975
to 1995 I could tell you at that time
every show that was on the air and
anybody who was in it even the crappy
shows that nobody watch I knew who it
was
Wow you know who
was Ricky Shorter's Butler on silver
spoons back then I would have known I
could tell you which show Morgan Britney
was on 1983 but then you know cable hit
and it exploded and and I got old as
happens to the lucky ones you and me not
Jimi Hendrix okay so so nerd goes into
Yale comes out with a did you stay for
graduate school no I I did audition for
Yale Drama School because I'm like I
don't know if I want to go to graduate
school but I guess if I get into Yale
Drama then I want to go to graduate
school I didn't get in
didn't get in came home to LA which is a
great fall back I mean if you want to be
in this business and home is LA not so
bad exactly I've you know I've been
really lucky all my life yeah and it
still took me you know quite a few years
to get up off the ground you know but
the one thing I had from college that
really I think fed me was I started
doing improv in college okay which would
then lead you to the groundlings yeah
yeah a buddy a buddy of mine from
Chicago studied with Del Close in summer
of 85 Wow came back with us like you
know like the man who had just come from
Mecca with the see this thing taught a
group of us how to do the herald that
long it this long for this new long form
at the time and so we formed a Herald
group and it blew my mind I had never
seen you know I think I seemed like you
know easy game improv but I had never
approached it on this level and it was
mind-blowing plus that summer we all as
a group went to Chicago studied with
Dell had him hip us to the Robert Anton
Wilson series of books the EOB the
Illuminati series and the widow's son
and like all of this incredibly like
this read this book this is what we're
doing in improv like Illuminati can
illuminati conspiracies and
subtext and hypertext and everything
like yeah you know I must been great for
like a D&D kid it was like I've just got
the books and books and books yes give
me things to study numbers show me the
formulas exactly the underthe canon of
comedy right and it was hilarious
because up until that point comedy was
just comedy stand-up comics you hey I'm
a wild and crazy guy
there was no studying of it although
what's funny speaking of black man on on
Batman I do think that there is because
there's been a lot of talk lately in
Groundlings and UCB about becoming a
know black people and I mean there's a
lot of funny black people mmm why aren't
they doing improv or why aren't they
getting you know rising levels in improv
and part of it is you know I won't say
blatant racism but unconscious racism
just because comedy is a gut thing hmm
and people respond to stuff on an
unconscious level and they respond to
the familiar and don't respond to the
unfamiliar I don't know you know she
just doesn't make me laugh
it's like because her characters don't
remind you of your own family
no that's not it yes it is um when you
do respond it's because it's Cosby
because he's being specifically generic
right like yeah well that's the thing
and there's also I think from the other
end a cultural element like you in order
to pursue an in improv you have to have
a grad school mentality and most black
Brown you know folks you know you know
and children of immigrants stuff if you
tell them it's like you have a wonderful
creative gift we want to charge you four
to six hundred dollars per month for you
to get better at that get like wait I'm
funny and you want me to pay you to go
be funny thank you I'm going to the I'm
going to the improv right I mean and
there's also that especially culturally
the idea that if you are black and
you're from wherever you're from the
people who are great at things are great
because they were always greater things
right you're an athlete you're super fun
you're just fast exactly you can shoot
you can
natural its natural not that of course
you don't have to study to get it lead
at it but if you're but people think you
know it's like man I never see Michael
Jordan practice like a certain practice
is every day every [ __ ] day I don't
see it man no I just get up there and I
ball you know people don't want to
practice people don't want to work
people don't want to study yeah they
don't understand or haven't been taught
that they need to understand right right
the the Malcolm Gladwell of it all
you've got to put your 10,000 hours in
you have to get great at this and
especially because if you're fun if
you're a funny kid
you're already making people laugh right
like you are you're doing the thing
you're getting the response I'm done hey
[ __ ] it maybe I do some stand-up maybe
bagging a little bit of money I don't
actually need to put in I don't have to
get under the hood and find out why I'm
funny I'm just funny you know it's why
you know you look at somebody like Tiger
Woods who whatever you know about him
today
but the idea that when he when his swing
was broken he took a year off to fix his
swing right like I'm gonna get under the
hood and find out why this doesn't work
Michael Jordan didn't have that leap
anymore it's like I'm gonna take a year
and find a jump shot right right you
know I need a mid-range jumper I can't
do that anymore I'm gonna learn how to
change yeah and it's hard to do if
you're 19 years old and funny right if
you're 16 years old and fast and and if
you don't have the mentality about
getting under the hood and understanding
the process about being being about
process yeah and I do I mean we'll back
to this later oh we don't have to we can
talk about it now but the fact that you
you know do the black version yes which
is an all black improv oh yes well
diverse well I mean our director is
Chinese Japanese what the [ __ ] that I
just like I have a known Karen Maruyama
for 25 years but yes it is all people of
color involved in the in the production
and white people holding the money just
to keep it straight just so we all know
we're all getting paid at the end of the
day you know how did you form that
nucleus like was it just a you know you
see people in like ohyou you you have
the shine you've got the glow I just
think you've got the steady wrinkles on
your forehead
no you know you just throw some scatman
and OH
yeah I know my buddy Jordan Jordan black
who was also in the groundlings and
actually a directed Jordan when he was
coming up through the groundings you
know as a black person in improv you are
a unicorn you are a rarity but what we
found is over time we found other
unicorns and he said you know what I'm
trying to be in all these herds of
horses let's get a herd of unicorns
together you know and he you know by
that point he knew enough people and he
gathered people from you know growlings
and other places and when we just formed
a group you know and it was it's been so
much fun how long's been going on we
started doing the black version in 2010
if anybody doesn't know black version is
a live improv show we do here in LA
where it's an all-black cast we take a
suggestion from the audience of a
classic or iconic movie and then we
improvise the black version of it you
know so our our premise is essentially
racist and we head down from there yeah
it's really fun I'm completely unfazed I
totally own PC I went once I got dragged
by a friend of mine and dragged in the
best way right right right
do you have to [ __ ] go it's so
amazing so I went and my suggestion got
chosen Oh what was yours Beauty and the
Beast beauty in them oh yeah because see
now it's funny because they're songs and
everything right we start getting into
like when we first started we thought
this will run for like three months then
we'll be done cuz I mean how many times
can you just do the black version okay
now I'm a beast Oh Bruce you you know
but we found that it's not just that the
it's not that the premise is limited
it's that it's simple and so it just
blows and it just goes and it goes and
it goes but that's funny there are a few
things Beauty and the Beast is tough we
don't usually do animated stuff although
not really any reason but buting beasts
is a lovely really white one and you
know it's so white
exactly well one time we dot we got Snow
White
and it was tough because nobody people
don't really watch the original and
animated snow white but everybody knows
the story of Snow White right so we were
able to get the references but what we
missed was that like dead-on
where you take a line from the movie or
a scene from the movie and flip it you
know like because the it exists in this
weird
ethereal like we all know it right but
we know 18 different versions of it
exactly we had the same problem with was
it it was the story of Moses great exit
kimber which version of the movie was
thing was before exes came out I think
we were doing greatest story ever itto
never told or something and like
everybody knows those Bible stories but
nobody got like if you do specifically
alright mad wordy robbers like people
ain't getting that reference right
exactly but but it still works you know
right
so that's once a month right yeah at
Largo down on La Cienega fantast I go to
cornet alright so so now let's plug away
so so Groundlings then Groundlings -
what does animation start there yeah no
no I did well I mean the original job
mr. T was animation but I don't really
count that because it was bad animation
and I wasn't was it a career I did
improv I did Groundlings I started doing
a lot of sitcom work and then I got mad
tv the animation actually starts there
okay because we had all these claymation
pieces produced by a guy named Corky
Quackenbush which were great also the
best name of the room yeah
like we had basically like the Scorsese
version of Rudolph the Red Nosed
Reindeer called raging Rudolph and it
was just like those those little cute
rankin/bass and claymation things just
bloody you know like Yukon kornelius
just like rips the head off of the the
Bominable snowman it's just like blood
everywhere
and so yeah that's and they use them the
cast to voice all of those animation
shows cuz
hey we're already paying them for the
episodes looks like and just stick them
in there we need to get June Foray in
here we got these people exactly and
that's where I really started getting my
first real mic time you know and like
understanding okay
and plus sketch characters stuff sort of
dovetails with you know voice-over
characters like okay you got to do it
quick you've got to get that character
across you know in a way that people can
grab on to fairly quickly and so it lent
I think it lent itself to when I started
doing animation which came around
towards the end of MADtv and right after
I left MADtv then I really started
pursuing it what was what was the big
takeaway from MADtv for you like going
both being in it and you hear these
stories legendary stories of SNL and
sketch comedy and the wringer and the
grinder and the weird sort of especially
nice to Nell the the the layers of
heritage and tradition right that seem
ridiculous to the outside like why do
you do it this way
I'm sure there's 20 better ways to do
this right but it's the way you've
always done it
like what sure I guess why not right
that's your jam Who am I to say no what
was it like was MADtv that same kind of
know what was it supposed to be
different by design different I don't
think there was much vision all they
thought was we've got this name we've
got this property and SNL wasn't funny
last year so we're gonna be the new SNL
which was hilarious because yeah yeah
that guy's just been standing there for
25 years you go knock him down be my
guess and the first year you know I
suppose we didn't really have a chance
but that was the idea as like we were
gonna take on SNL why second season we
were copying SNL we had they like gave
up the fight quick it's like oh there's
a guest host who's doing a monologue
what's the news segment seriously that
that was our second season like him wait
wait guys we're supposed to be the
alternative NASA no yeah yeah by
alternative would mean a half hour
earlier so big night though so my
takeaway from MADtv was you should have
a vision but even if you don't you may
run for 50 15 years hey you know their
shows in the air then I've run out of
vision three episodes in you know but my
thing was you have a choice you know and
I remember talking to somebody about
this early on like well the network
wants to do this like one wife listen to
the network well what do you want to be
like the Ben Stiller show you'll have
one season and gone and take home a
shitload of Emmys and go into movie
careers yes yes I do that is exactly
what I want hold on all of this seems
like a good idea what part of this are
you not getting right exactly like oh
like I just want a steady job like no
don't you want to be great good enough
good enough for the guys above to keep
writing me a check and that is that I
guess that's a vision of a sort it
totally is I mean it's a vision of the
happy retirement right right nobody
remembers your name when that's
grandma's I was amazing remember a lot
of work we got I know I'm sorry
so now Deena did pulp fiction come in
the middle of MADtv pulp fiction came
before MADtv whoo yeah cuz we started
Matt in 95
shot pulp fiction in 93 came out in 97
of 94 yeah conv summer 94 and he was
still in the theaters when we started
meant to be because our first episode
had a pulp fiction parody because of
course it did that's what happens when
you're pulp fiction right everything is
gonna power to you because your pulp
fiction exactly so what was what was
your way in like how did how did you end
up in the back of that car shun the face
again back to improv mmm
Julia Sweeney was friends with Quentin
Tarantino and got him to come do our
show we do at the ground cooking with
gas we do an improv show with a special
celebrity guest he was a celebrity guest
and I was in the cast and he and I met
there and then when he was cast in the
movie he remembered me look at that you
know and asked me to come in and read
that was the most fun audition
I heard it did you read for Marvin at a
jury
well coz Marvin didn't really have any
lines and Quentin is smart enough to
know I was like I don't want to hear
somebody's safe three unconnected lines
let's do a scene and so we had us
audition with the Jules Bret hamburger
scene I mean that's just like being
handed us you know sizzling sirloin
steak like you want some yeah I mean the
writing is so good like you know you
practice this by the time I read through
it three times I had this [ __ ] memorized
cuz every line is the line that should
come after the line before it just even
though it's like this heightened
language and these completely
unrealistic scenarios it all just flows
now is he is he the kind of guy and I've
heard buried versions of this but I I
tend to imagine him a bit like Aaron
Sorkin which is my words are not to say
sacrosanct but they're written to be
spoken and to be spoken a certain way
does Quentin allow for you to come in
and improvise or does he say like I know
I get it but this is the way it's
supposed to lay on the page this is the
way it lays in your head
um I think because we had rehearsals
before we shot because it was really low
budgets like an eight million dollar
budget so you know we could not waste
time you had pages you needed to do you
know what I think Quentin I can't really
compare him to any I mean ever was a lot
of good people and some people have been
very like we've written the words his
[ __ ] is so good you don't want to
improvise you don't need to it's like
because improvising comes when you're
like wait wait oh but you come up with a
better idea you ain't coming up with no
better ideas the the only two things in
that movie that change from that script
are that I get shot once instead of
twice because John Travolta thought ooh
that second shot I'm doing that on
purpose
because what was supposed happen it's
like you know he turns around like come
on gotta have an opinion God came down
from heaven and some man goes in the
throat oh and I'm still Oh gurgling
which is funny well they're going back
oh man what the [ __ ] you do it like
Hobbit in the throat
well what do you don't do that boy was
like oh and then they decide well we got
to put him out of his misery on a count
of three I'm gonna hit the horn
run two and then they get covered in
blood hmm and then everything goes the
way it's an Travolta I think rightly
said if I shoot this kid on purpose the
audience is gonna hate me mm-hmm and
Quentin said oh you're right and they
changed the only other thing that
changed is the pig reference in in the
the diner like windows Jules and Vincent
are talking about pork right it's like
you know like what like if a pig had a
better personality
it's the dog you talking about but that
whole thing we write originally supposed
be we have to be talking moment Charmin
[ __ ] Pig that's me - Cary Grant
of pigs and Sam didn't got did not think
that Jules would think Cary Grant was
all that cool that's legit and I'm like
okay I can see that he's not a man who
grew up watching North by Northwest
right so they change it to Arnold from
Green Acres sure why not okay it it fits
it totally fits it's funny I was
watching a die-hard the other day
speaking of Travolta not wanting to be
that hated like we know he's a bad guy
right you don't want to hate him no
can't I am convinced the only reason why
in die hard there's the scene where
where where Alan Rickman shoots Takagi
when they're sitting down trying to get
the vault and he's like right you know
we can talk about men's fashion all
David work must be done I need the codes
to the thing the only reason he kills
him there because otherwise you want
Alan Rickman you want Hans Gruber to win
yes he is yes [ __ ] charming he is so
he's figured about that like you respect
that guy's plan and his brain to the
point which and they changed the accents
all that [ __ ] everything like I want him
to get away with it right you gotta kill
Takagi so that you now
like you have a reason to want John
McClane to stop right look we don't want
to hate Vincent Vega we want to like it
exactly he's got to kill it do by
accident not on purpose right
really [ __ ] smart so now what happens
after pulp fiction like after can after
all of that stuff like what does that do
for you nothing huh
nothing at all nothing about dude I'm I
play the guy got his brains blown on the
back of the car there's not a lot of
those parts hey Phil we we've got a guy
who gets a shot in the side of the head
in this next picture we'd love for you
to I mean cuz there's not really like
it's funny because I remember right
after it came out trying to cut together
something for my reel hmm a mic
hey you [ __ ] here there's me cowering in
a corner that's that's not a good
audition scene hmm which is why Quentin
didn't have the audition with [ __ ]
Marvin's lines it was a wonderful
conversation piece and there was
definitely in the mid-80s a bunch of
auditions that I got just so people
could ask me about Quentin Wow you know
like I'm convinced that that in the same
way that they're actors on the wire who
whether they want it the whole time or
whether they just got shot in a corner
somewhere right that is the reason they
get into a room it's like oh yeah well
it's like being on the wire that was one
of the guys that he calls on the phone
and I drop a bag of things into a car
and he walks away that must have been
great but that's that's the way it works
on all levels but if you have something
that's shown because people have
positive associations toward things like
oh my god I love the wires the best
thing and they wanted some of that juice
with their project they'll hire somebody
for the wires just so their show feels
more like the wire you know in the
office to feel more like the wires yes
we do oh three episodes you know and I
mean it's funny because you do see that
like on Justice League
I think all but one of the cast of
Firefly guest it on Justice League
at some point in in our in our series
just cuz like everybody because I think
it's because Bruce and the guys loved
Firefly
you know legit you know and some of
those guys are awesome and of course not
all of them were great you weren't
feeling in almost everything yes is that
dude sounds like a hero right yeah I
think that what the custom is a custom
is a vigilante yeah that's a cowboy
right you look at that dude
maybe it's a cowboy you played a space
cowboy right superhero cowboy about a
detective cowboy mm-hmm so now now when
the the voice-over stuff started heating
up like when you went into it was it
because there are voiceover actors who
just do a voice like I'm Kevin Conroy
I'm giving you Batman I'm not going to
give you somebody else like this is my
speed right when did you decide that
like you know what I could do Phil
Lamarr but I can also do these 19 other
things and help you get where you're
going right you know like not that
you're you know Maurice LaMarche this
time it's not like you're inventing like
Oh Mel Blanc no but you still were able
to give you a kaleidoscope of well know
the truth the matter is when I started
out I couldn't do Phil Lamarr mm-hmm you
know someone said we want your own voice
like I don't know it's like [ __ ]
I grew up code-switching
I don't know like there there isn't
there's no there's no there there you
know my my natural voice when in a room
full of white people in a room full of
black people which boys which me do you
want so and also coming from sketch I
was all about chameleon eyes you know if
somebody said oh my god I don't even
know that was you that was the ultimate
compliment to me so I was always trying
to find a new sound a new voice a new
placement for whatever character how
exhausting do you get when you do that
like if you've got to get into a place
and do this voice and then for 25
episodes of something be in that voice
like how difficult is that to summon
when you need to summon um it's harder
at the beginning cuz you don't have
anything to latch on to usually what
happens is you they record that first
you know audition or that first
recording session where you did that
voice and then they play it back for you
and then you're like okay let me let me
refine that although what I find is by
the time the you know first episode
animation comes around and once I see it
the character because voice is really
only a third of the character he's not
the whole character but once I see the
whole thing there I'm like oh oh okay
now I can just imitate that guy and then
it locks in you know but yeah it's it's
it takes concentration it takes for it
ain't like I'm digging a ditch a hard
work it's a skill right every day bad as
it is you're not actually doing the
labor right right I say things like
crack jokes when I'm not like it's all
good right we can make this happen
right right so now what I it's gonna be
hard asking somebody what the favorite
thing is everything is [ __ ]
but I do want to ask you about the idea
like playing Jon Stewart playing Green
Lantern and what that meant to people
because I remembered Kevin did an
interview on podcast and talking about
the decision to make Ryan Reynolds to do
Hal Jordan right in the movies and it's
Green Lantern and the idea that there's
a generation of kids who grew up that
was a real aunt to Jon Stewart Lantern
and way more kids have seen that version
of the character then read the comic
books and read any of the comic books
not over the course of 70 years of Green
Lantern but as far as kids growing up
now right the last 10 years more people
have been exposed to that so what does
it mean to you going into that did you
understand what that response and they
would be like no oh yeah come on man
excuse me you don't know there's no way
to know and anybody who starts out on
the first episode of a television show
thinking about legacy is an [ __ ]
seriously you know you are if you've got
that much ego I mean you could it could
happen you know James Cameron's made
some great [ __ ] movies but generally
your job is to make it
is to get it to from idea to reality to
fruition what happens after that you
have no control over you know Justice
League could have been canceled after a
single season you know they could have
changed you know the head of Cartoon
Network he's like uh why are those
people all wearing tight pants that
seems weird kids today are wearing baggy
pants let's cancel that superhero show
you have no idea but afterwards you know
and this is what's been interesting in
the last couple of years going to
conventions and seeing the effect of its
seeing the legacy I mean there was a
sense of responsibility because
obviously these are these characters had
a long history and you know tons of
tradition behind them and I know that
Bruce Timm I asked him when we first
started out like cuz I'm gonna come from
guys like y-you do i Jon Stewart instead
of how cuz I mean as all of us
comic-book guys know Hal is the Green
Lantern of Earth and his thing was like
well frankly I didn't want to do a show
or seven white people save the earth
every week that's fair and I mean Bruce
is thinking ahead you know and thinking
in terms of his responsibilities as a
broadcaster you know which I get you
know
now obviously you don't know that it's
gonna have that effect
you know when Dennis and Alan Burnett
started doing static shock you know we
won our time slot for four years but we
didn't have any toys and we got canceled
cuz Saturday morning was about toys not
ratings and not enough and we all felt a
responsibility we were the only you know
show with a a black kid as the superhero
only one so there was definitely a sense
of responsibility we don't know who is
gonna watch this or how many of them but
for whoever does watch it we're taking
it seriously
yeah it's funny I yeah I wrote the last
two issues of static shock the comic
book which Verde the original verse to
the new one right back
for eight issues they handed me my last
two they canceled the book before my
first issue came out and my big question
was always like listen I understand the
numbers are what the numbers are right
and you're making a business decision
that's totally fine but of all these
counties in the new 52 that are not
Superman Batman and Wonder Woman
there was a deeper market penetration
for static than there was for almost
anyone else because it had a show for
four years right as it did well in the
ratings people watched it for a decent
amount of time if you can't figure out
how to sell a comic book to the people
who've already watched this character
and love this character for a long time
write me what's up I don't yeah like I
don't understand how you can't do that
mm-hmm but comics is also like we talked
a little bit before about how television
is a broken medium right looks it's a
little bit broken too and well and
there's there's entrenched patterns some
people are aware of some people aren't
you know but they're there right yeah
but like hey I understand that the
people who you normally sell comics to
might not want this right but there is
an audience there and we see it
increasingly it's starting to come and
starting to bubble
especially with female audiences like oh
oh you mean they'll buy comic books if
you make comic books for women yeah yeah
we're not even like for them but just
not anti them yes exactly
they'll put them in a goddamn
refrigerator yeah that would be first
step let's not rape and murder them and
leave them to be found by the hero to
their motivate him to do something and
and let's it let's give them spines yeah
that's what the women have spines maybe
that we're like that the back break the
width oh my god yeah just a couple of
those I mean you know everybody loves a
little something let's do versa no I
need nobody's saying you can't have
pneumatic breasts no but you can't show
her pneumatic breasts and her ass at the
same time is it just not physically
possible you've gotten to pick got to
pick okay so yes we've talked about your
your vast panoply and yes if anybody is
still listening and watching let's move
up let's move on
what else do you want to do like what is
what is on the to-do list for phil
lamarr like i you know i've done movies
have done TV i've done voice work i've
done you know episodic i've done all of
this thing what what drives you what is
the question that drives you um
it's well basically I want to keep doing
it I want to keep doing
I mean basically do a play every three
years my bum jump back and forth between
on-camera and you know a little bit of
movie here did Jason Reitman less movie
and then do some TV stuff I just did a
guest spot on Lucifer you know just so
much fun
and then I got to keep my voice over
stuff going I would love to just keep
you know even from the buffet but you
know I'm also feeling like well what
else can I do and like as an actor who
like was an English major and can't put
two words together I'm like why haven't
I written anything so I'm that's where
I'm headed currently got a couple of
writing projects and developing a thing
that hopefully we will launch at the end
of this year or a beginning of next but
it's gonna be a really really really
cool fun geek oriented project ooh I
like the sound of that yeah there's
gonna be deke oriented things make me
happy
yes yeah so gonna be writing and
producing that yeah I want to just you
know like I've got you know all the legs
of my stool I would just want to keep
adding legs and keep spreading my [ __ ] I
wanna kind you career it's not like that
no we don't want your career to be
raping things no no you know what the
real the octopus is nature's friend
there's a peaceful creature even the
ones in Japan you know they hardly ever
rape thing exactly I feel I'm gonna let
you get back to being the busiest man in
show business all right
this listen you got
if you want to just like drop into a
Netflix K hole look up this dude's
filmography and just L just watch it
[ __ ] you could watch it for the rest of
your natural-born life and still not get
to the bottom of everything well but you
also need to be watching I guess what
yeah Samurai Jack is on Netflix you got
to catch up ah you haven't watched
Samurai Jack you got to because I just
came from working on one of the episodes
of the new the new Adult Swim mini run
[Music]
that dissipation no listen
fill them on thank you so much thanks
Marcos okay and Kevin thanks for being
in Canada yes you can stay for as long
as you like my friend we're holding down
here on black man on bad man that's
right listen we'll see you same time
next episode same fat place all the
things Kevin says so my cast that comes
last fat man likes Kevin Smith
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith take it
easy guys
[Music]
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder